[Music]
what's going on guys
Despicable Me 3 is hitting theaters and
you know what that means
minions there's going to be a
significant rise in minion related
activity including memes people love
making memes out of the minions we did a
deep dive and found a lot of these means
some were funny some were inspirational
and then some started to get weird and
frankly disturbing we have a chance to
sit down with Steve Carell Kristen Wiig
and Miranda Cosgrove
voice actors from the new Despicable Me
film and we decided instead of asking
them questions let's just show them
these memes check it out
Steve Kristen so excited to be here with
you and congrats on making a super fun
movie thank you now the word on the
street about you guys is that you love
means and today yep I guess wrong with
no thank you
so Miranda I wanted to show you some
Despicable Me okay okay and these are
memes that are inspired by your movie
you can find them all on my aunt's
Facebook page so if you wouldn't mind I
want to walk through a couple of these
Despicable Me
I am so confused I love that so sweet
yeah okay they get a little weird or
maybe I am Wonder Woman okay yeah Oh
sounds like my aunt we're not so true oh
that would make me feel a little sad
because she just looks so sweet and
clueless yep okay you know my name not
my story see my spine I'm Anne Wow this
is see that's very intense yes
not me right now what does this have to
do with Despicable Me I don't know if it
is real yes these are real memes okay I
don't think I understood that they were
totally react oh no I didn't get that
either yeah if you think that's weird
what is one what's what what's going on
the CEO stare what Wow wait and why is
spoiling and why is why is there a
minion with this clothes is very that is
very strange I guess they're just using
minions
- well you don't see I get it I get it
because minions are so accessible and
fun how about this it's been a rough
week but on a positive note I didn't
need any bail money and didn't have to
hide any body part but that's why it's
22 just another woman steals your man
there's a better event but really online
can't be stolen that gets in that right
yeah touches me oh it's kinda cute but I
thought this is another thing a little
confused on like they're all minions men
because like you know feels like they
are like yeah our minions male or female
or they just neuter how would a poor
oral minion berming is just hatched I
really like me there's like a worm is
like does not have a gender fun me me
and me Mike yeah boy I know right they
don't know about the appropriateness of
that you know the crossover but and I
did I mean Julian fun oh I've never seen
them like that yeah oh my gosh these
minions are super buff their minion
strippers um strip yinz I'd love to see
these two franchises come together that
would be an interesting they want them
and one more oh there you go don't scare
me I could easily
hello gross okay I'll accept it yeah
that I guess that's more in keeping cute
well I have arranged with your agents
and publicists to make sure you get an
email link with all of these great I was
going to ask about that and thanks for
walking through some despicable meetings
thanks for bringing a man well that was
a good time and you know what I think a
couple of those memes are going to haunt
my nightmares who do you have a favorite
one or can you make up a despicable beam
right now post it in the comment section
below we want to see it also some kind
of excited about some of you may know
that I do comedy outside of screen
junkies well I'm going to be appearing
on this season of America's Got Talent
as a comedy character I play named Eric
Jennifer for more info follow at Eric
Jennifer on Twitter or visit Eric
Jennifer calm I want to thank you for
watching screen junkies hit me up on
Twitter or Eric Jennifer up on Twitter
I'll see you next time bye like
[Music]